Nottingham Castle was built nearly a
thousand years ago as an impregnable
Norman Fortress even as a tourist
attraction though it's just as
inaccessible owned by the council it's
been closed since November when its
trust went into liquidation
the castle is a symbol of a city and of
a council that struggled financially in
the two years since it lost 38 million
pounds on a failed company Robin Hood
energy
that's meant cuts to vital services like
base 51 a youth center just around the
corner from the castle which has only
six months left in this property unless
it gets more funding before I started
coming here I was going out getting into
trouble
but since I started coming here to offer
counseling and
obviously that's hoping got onto a
better path well I'm here I'll be
getting trouble every day basically I'd
probably get arrested by now
Nottingham was forced to issue what's
known as a section 114 notice an
official Declaration of financial
distress it's not the only one Slough
thoric Croydon have done the same within
the last year and woking has warned it
might have to as well
the notices have come as councils
receive much less funding from central
government this shows the decline over
the last eight years a nearly 90 percent
drop
councils have had to find money
elsewhere Sky News analysis reveals that
some are now spending more on servicing
debt than they are on providing services
spellthorne for instance spends more
than one and a half times more although
the council told us the income from
their Investments outweighs the debt
working in Surrey has racked up nearly 2
billion pounds in debt investing in
property developments like this and it's
in danger of running out of cash
you might ask why a commuter town like
woking needs a Skyline like Singapore
but these towers are the products of a
system whose demands whose incentives
have changed with less funding from
central government councils were urged
to find new revenue streams councils
were told to be Innovative
entrepreneurial it's act like any other
company and this involved Investments
property other sort of Investments maybe
outside their own local Authority area
Nottingham City Council also told us
that because they're receiving less
money in government grants they're
cutting services they would prefer not
to including funding the base 51 Youth
Center
but the council also made a terrible bet
on Robinhood energy for which they
deserve blame so does the funding system
that incentivizes those bets Tom
Cheshire Sky News Nottingham